so i just finished my round five game
from the abu dhabi masters tournament
and this was a really crazy one uh i
don't want to spoil the results but
let's get into it
i was playing wim rucha pujari from
india
and she actually has a twitch channel um
i'll leave a link below to uh to her
channel if you want to follow her goes
by ruches27 on twitch i believe
and she's uh
she's a good player um i prepared for
her a little bit and
before the game i decided that i would
play
a new first move that i have not played
this tournament pawn to c4
and uh this provoked her to think for a
couple minutes on move one
because my first game this tournament i
played london with d4 and um
against joe bava i played e4
so
kind of running the gamut of all the the
first moves maybe next game is white
i'll play knight f3
but i played the english um with
intention to transpose into a queen's
game declined which is exactly what we
got
and i opted for the exchange variation
and this is actually a line that i play
for black
i very rarely play this as white but i
figured that i already have a lot of
experience in these structures why not
play it for the opposite color
and the move i was actually expecting
here was bishop f5
the so-called positional line and if you
watch my match with uh gotham chess
lobby rosman you'll know that i played
this line as black with pretty good
success during the match
but she didn't go into this instead she
played bishop e7
which i knew was a possibility i found a
few games from her with this move i
played bishop d3
and we continued developing this is a
very kind of standard queen's gambit
structure the so-called carlsbad
structure where
black is missing in e pawn white's
missing a c pawn so it's a little bit
imbalanced uh she goes for a typical
plan of rookie eight
and then uh g6 which caught me a little
bit by surprise
usually black starts with knight f8
first and then decides whether to put
the knight here or go for like this g6 i
should explain actually the point of g6
is uh
kind of a long-term positional idea to
go for knight f8 knight e6 knight g7 and
the vengeful bishop f5 to trade off
uh kind of the inferior bishop for black
um so i think there's nothing wrong with
g6 i'm not sure how theoretical this
this is
but i continue here with bishop to f4
and
it looks weird moving my bishop
that was already developed on g5 back to
f4 but
because there is no longer a pin
and the bishop is just happier more
towards the center on the longer
diagonal
i figured this was a good use of my time
and there's actually a trap behind this
move too
is that if black uh is overly tempted to
grab the bishop pair
then there's a really nice move for
white in this position
feel free to pause the video if you want
to try and find the
tactic to win material but the move is
knight takes d5
and um i've seen this probably when i
was like very young in like random chess
puzzle books the point being that if
takes bishop c7 traps the queen
and if knight takes f4 i can take back
with knight so white would win a clean
pawn in the sun
but she did not fall into that trap
rather played 9 f8
i play h3
um because maybe 9 h5 was a threat given
the queen has more air to breathe so i
free up a square for the bishop on h2
she plays knight e6 i play bishop e5
and now b6
and um
yeah we're pretty much entering the
middle game phase
and it's a very rich position there's uh
still a lot of ideas uh to consider for
white but the move i ended up going for
is actually kind of a tricky move i
decided to play pawn b4
and then i said oh no my pawn
and then she thought for a little bit
and took it
um and
i didn't actually say oh no my pawn but
she did
take the pawn uh which was kind of a
surprise because i thought the pawn
was was just poisonous
so the reason for playing before
i should explain just from a positional
standpoint is to go for the eventual
minority attack and weaken the
black pawn structure
now i didn't think she could get away
with this because of essentially what
happened the game
i take the knight
queen takes f6
and i take on d5
and it's kind of a cool tactical
combination because after
pawn takes knight i have queen c6 and
white is winning back material there is
no way to hold on to the extra piece for
black
now i will admit that when i played b4
i thought i was going to be winning
material at the end of this line
but it actually turns out that it's just
a trade after she plays bishop to d7 i
take
and it's back to equal material so
the last several moves were just kind of
a fancy way of exchanging pieces
but i think the position transformed in
white's favor because now
first of all the d5 pawn is a very big
weakness
and i have easy access to the c file
and it's hard for black to actually
contest the c file in a lot of positions
because there's potential for bishop a6
and i think the harmony is just a bit
more pleasant for white
so i was feeling good here
but the game keeps going rook d8 queen
b5 bishop d6 i improve
she retreats i go in with the rook queen
b7
a lot of these moves are very very
natural knight c7
drop back with the queen
and then b5
and um
yeah as we can see white's position is
like extremely pleasant black is a
little bit
uh tied down with with the pieces um
pretty much purely defensive
uh for black here
and it's a question how
i can make progress as white
given that my pieces are all like pretty
happy
and i decided here to go for a very
explosive center break pawn to e4
and i was very happy when i spotted this
move
because it does transform the position
but it creates a lot of
dangerous tactical possibilities
and while i played this move i thought i
was going to be winning relatively
quickly
because there's a lot of lines where
black just can get crushed
for example if pawn takes
uh i was even considering a move like
knight to g5 hitting f7
and like rook f8 is not possible because
rook takes d6
could also maybe just take back with the
bishop and there's all this uh
all sorts of problems for black in this
position
so she did not take the pawn but rather
played rook d7 which i think was a good
practical try just uh
trying to hold things together and
giving me a choice here
um and i actually
spent some time trying to figure out
whether i should take whether to push
but i decided to keep all the tension
and played the move queen c2
creating the triple battery
on the file
and uh really just trying to maximize
the pressure here
now in hindsight i probably should have
played queen c3
with the same idea
but
not allowing the move that she played in
the game
uh because after queen c2 this allows
knight a6
and
i thought this was still better for me
but knight a6 is actually kind of an
annoying move because she is threatening
knight before
with a
triple fork
and um
it's not easy to prevent because a3
there's bishop takes a3
now i saw this coming and i played rook
to c8 but after we trail on c8
she plays king g7
it's not so easy for white to
[Music]
like win material here at first i
thought i should be winning a pawn
somehow
just given that there's so many
different targets in the position the
knight
for the time being is misplaced
and initially i thought i could take
take and play
rook c6
but um
why did i not do this
ah yeah there's some rook b6 move like
maybe black can take first
or maybe just rip b6 immediately
and uh yeah i didn't quite see a clear
clear edge here for white maybe white's
still better but
i decided not to go for queen b7 right
away
i started with e5
and uh bishop a3 i think is a very
precise move
um i was hopeful that we could go into
something like this bishop uh e7 would
walk into a4 and this is a really nice
resource exploiting the fact that b-pawn
is pinned
and i think white is winning material
here so bishop a3
is useful in preventing a4
and attacking the rook
uh so i decided to trade queens
and materials still equal but i still
thought i'm playing for
some advantage
and around here she offered a draw
uh real quick i'll check the move number
yeah actually after
her next move bishop e7 she offered to
draw
um now as we see by the time situation
i had a pleasant time advantage and i
still thought i was uh like decently
better here with
the more space in the center nice center
pawns uh the fact that my pieces are
just more centralized a bit more
coordinated
so
uh yeah i decided like right after she
uh offered the draw i was not gonna
accept the draw
but uh the more i thought in this
position the more i realized it's really
not easy to
um to make clear progress as white
because black has some annoying knight
before idea
and i was trying to figure out uh just a
clear plan and i decided to just
gradually improve with king f1
she plays knight b4
i defend the pawn hold on to my bishop
now she plays a5
and yeah black is actually getting some
sufficient counter play
but the game keeps going king e2
a4
knight d2
knight a6
and now pawn f4
so
around this point i was still optimistic
that uh
now i have kind of a clear plan of
playing g4 f5
someday f6 to just keep the pawns
rolling
but uh it's black who who also has some
some chances on the queen side and she
starts with knight c7 here which uh yeah
nice move just solidifying and preparing
potential knight e6
i play rook c6
and now she plays b4
and i think in hindsight i may have
underestimated these pawns like i
thought there's no way that the pawns
can cause me any issues because
whenever b3 is played i can just take
and then the b-pawn would probably be
more of a weakness and a strength
but what i had underestimated is after
she played b4
uh the intention is actually to play
knight b5 and knight c3
and this is a really dangerous threat
and uh as we're gonna see it gets really
really tricky
after i play bishop c2 hitting the pawn
she
plays knight b5 and now she says oh no
my pawn and of course i can't take it
because knight's c3 so
i played king d3 getting out of
potential checks
and she plays brook a7 defending the
pawn
i play rook b6
and when i played rook b6 i had thought
that after knight c3 which she did play
i thought i could play a3
and then i realized
a3 is actually a losing move for white i
just assumed that if takes takes
and a2 king b2
but what i had missed is there's rook c7
in between move my king has to move back
away from the pawn and then a2 and all
of a sudden black is winning
so this is a pretty serious oversight
and
if i can't play a3 here
i think white is actually in big trouble
and as we see by the time situation i am
getting lower on time
but uh it very soon turns into a blitz
game
and uh yeah there's not too many other
options for me to hold on to the pawn
uh really other than bishop d1 is what i
ended up playing
after about a four minute think
and now here
the tides are turning and i'm in trouble
because after rook
c7 rook a6
she takes takes
and then infiltrates with the rook
and now it's me who's
trying to hold on for dear life and i'm
not entirely sure
where things went wrong maybe the fact
that i just missed
this uh knight b5 knight c3 idea and
didn't
be a bit more careful
but
yeah here i thought i was in serious
trouble and like very close
to uh just completely losing but
thankfully i do have um
some chances to survive here with knight
d2
and then after rook c3
king e2 rook a3
when i saw this position from a distance
i thought
like white's just in big trouble because
rook takes a two is coming black is
going to get two connected past pawns
very close to queening but by some
miracle
i have one last bit of counter play is
to play rook a7
and
it's not so clear if black can
actually actually win this or even be
better here because i'm hitting the
bishop
and there's not too many ways to defend
the bishop because my pawns control all
these squares
and if the bishop moves then there's
pawn e6
and black actually has to be really
careful here because e7 is coming and
um yeah i think this would be a mess but
i'm still not sure what's going on here
so i played rook a7 and uh
at this point she's falling below a
minute she plays king to f8
and i have nothing better than to give a
check and repeat the position
and she thought for
maybe about a minute because she didn't
have more time she plays king f8
i check in g7 i go back
and we
agreed to a draw in in this position
and uh yeah the game ended peacefully
after a really topsy-turvy fight where
i really thought i had
great winning chances in the middle game
and then
in the end game i i think i probably
should have been losing at some point
but
i guess i can't complain with a draw
given that
i was very close to losing this game
now i haven't analyzed with engine and i
am really curious to check what
stockfish thinks
so
first i'll look at the final position
and just verify that this is actually a
draw but uh
i wouldn't be surprised if black is
somehow winning let's see
oh
so that could keep the game going it
looks like
but minus 0.2
indicates that it should be a draw so
bishop h4 i would play e6
and then ah king f8
is a try for black takes and then king
e8
yeah even though i have this cool
looking past e pawn and black is
guaranteed to win this and
uh looks like i have to play very
precisely to hold on so
i guess i i should be fortunate that she
didn't go for this given that the
position could have been very difficult
to defend
um now i want to go back earlier and see
like did i have any clear wins
man yeah i was like
much much better
but anything obvious rook d7
engine wants g3 here
queen c2 is fine
ah it wants me to go back
so rook c8 seems to be the the big
blunder
um
and yeah i guess queen c2
the idea of queen c2 rook c8 wasn't good
so i just had to play any other move
yeah e5
it's crazy that all these pawn moves are
good for whites
ah what to do
okay so and if we go forward
yeah this was just close to equal
now i'm curious if she was ever
completely winning
but she actually played like very very
nicely here to get counter play
and
yeah as we see black is better oh i
could have been losing
wait b3 if it takes
i saw this but bishop b1
rook a7 bishop a2
knight a6
wow okay
yeah i could have been losing this um if
she found this line
uh
during the game i saw i'd seen this idea
that i thought i could just blockade
but black just has too much firepower on
the queen side
um so what happened
yeah some big fluctuations here
oh a3 a3 first
yeah pawns are so dangerous
what a crazy game
so i was winning and then she was
winning
and then it was a draw very wholesome
finish
okay i think it's dinner time
i hope people enjoyed this game this
analysis uh if you have questions leave
them below
i'll also link to the live broadcast
where you can find this game and all
other games from this tournament
and
yeah as as gotham chess would say
get out of here